hi I'm Connor - Brian and instead of  doing yet another promo from my new show  coming this November on TBS I'm gonna  give you guys what you really want  top-notch entertainment check it out I  went out and I bought this 1969 Dodge  Dart I'm gonna get in it I'm gonna drive  right off that cliff into Devil's drop  Canyon a 900 foot sheer fall that's not  all we're loading the trunk of this baby  with 80 pounds of plastique the most  powerful explosive in the world yeah  dousing it with 40 gallons of gasoline  packing it with illegal fireworks from  the state of New Hampshire and up front  600 pounds of unpopped popcorn yeah  that's a stuff and all the while I'll be  accompanied by the world's famous  Habsburg Chamber Orchestra hey maestro  crank it up  how are you I do my own stunts  some check out my show or don't you've  got a movie to watch I've got a car to  drive off a cliff  [Music]  [Music]  that was expensive  [Music]  [Music]  premieres November 8th only on TBS very  funny